I was informed by this kind of
unoriginal and trite idea that new
technologies were an opportunity for
social transformation which is what
drove me then and still it's a delusion
that drives me now I wanted to update on
what I've been doing since then but it's
still the same theme song and introduce
you to my lab and current work which is
the environmental health clinic that I
run at NYU and what it is it's a twist
on health because really what I'm trying
to do now is redefine what counts as
health it's a clinic like a health
clinic at any other university except
people come to the clinic with
environmental health concerns and they
walk out with prescriptions for things
they can do to improve environmental
health as opposed to coming to a clinic
with medical concerns and walking out
with prescriptions for pharmaceuticals
and so handy-dandy quote from
Hippocrates of the Hippocratic oath that
says the greater part of the soul lies
outside the body treatment of the inner
requires treatment of the outer but that
suggests the the issue that I'm trying
to get out here that we have an
opportunity to redefine what is health
because this idea that health is
internal and atomized and individual and
pharmaceutical is largely in error and I
would use this study a recent study by
Philip Landrigan to motivate a different
view of health where he went to most of
the pediatricians in Manhattan and the
New York area and logged what they spent
their patient hours on 80 to 90 percent
of their time was spent on five things
number one was asthma
number two was developmental delays
number three was 400 folder increases in
rare childhood cancers in the last eight
to ten 15 years number four and five
were childhood obesity and diabetes
related issues so all of those what's
common about all of those the
environment is implicated radically
implicated right this is not the germs
that
médicos were trained to deal with this
is a different definition of
health that is has a great advantage
because it's external it's shared we can
do something about it as opposed to
internal genetically predetermined or
individualized people who come to the
clinic are called not patients but in
patients because they're too impatient
to wait for legislative change to
address local environmental health
issues and I meet them at the University
I also have a few field officers that I
set up in various places that provide an
immersion in some of the environmental
challenges we face I like this one from
the Belgium field office where we met in
a roundabout precisely because the
roundabout ikana fied the headless
social movement that informs much social
transformation as opposed to the
top-down control of red light traffic
intersections in this case of course the
roundabout with that micro decisions
being made institute by people not being
told what to do but of course affords
greater throughput fewer accidents and
an interesting model of social movement
some of the things that the monitoring
protocols I've developed this is the
tadpole bureaucrat protocol or keeping
tabs if you will what they are is a
addition of tadpoles that are named
after a local bureaucrats whose
decisions affect your water quality so
an impatient concern for water quality
would be would raise a tadpole
bureaucrat in their sample of water
which they're interested and we give
them a couple of things to do that to
help them do companion animal devices
while they're logging and doing their
email this is a tadpole Walker to take
your tadpole out walking in the evening
and the interesting thing that happens
because we're using tadpoles of course
because they are the most exquisite
biosensors that we have several orders
of magnitude more sensitive than some of
our sensors for for sensing responding
in a biologically meaningful way to that
whole class of industrial contaminants
we call endocrine disruptors or hormone
emulators but by taking your tadpole out
for a walk in the evening there's a few
action shots your neighbors unlikely to
say what are you doing and then you have
to introduce your tadpole and who it's
named after you have to explain what
you're doing and how the developmental
events of a tadpole are course very
observable and they use the same t3
mediated hormones that we do and so they
the next time you know your neighbor
sees you they'll say how is that tadpole
doing and you can let them social
network with your tadpole because the
environmental health clinic has a social
networking site for not only impatience
humans but nonhumans social networking
for humans and nonhumans and of course
these endocrine disruptors are things
that are implicated in the breast cancer
epidemic the obesity epidemic the
two-and-a-half year drop in the average
age of onset of menarche
in young girls and other related things
their combination of this is if you've
successfully raised your tadpole
observing the behavioral and
developmental events you will then go
and introduce your tadpole to its
namesake and discuss the evidence that
you've seen another quick protocol and
I'm going to go through these quickly
but just to give you the material sense
of what we're doing here instead of
asking you for urine samples
I'll ask you for a mouse sample anyone
here lucky enough to share to cohabit
with a mouse a domestic partnership with
mice very lucky mice of course the
quintessential model organism they're
even better models of environmental
health because not only the same and
mainly in biology but they share your
diet largely they share your
environmental stressors the asbestos
levels and that levels whatever you're
exposed to and they're geographically
more
Limited than you are because we don't
know if you've been exposed to
persistent organic pollutants in your
home or in occupationally or as a child
my some very good representation so it
starts by building a better mousetrap of
course this is one of them you know in
coping with environmental stressors as
tricky does anybody here on
antidepressants there's a lot of a lot
of people in Manhattan and this way we
were testing if the the mice would also
self administer SSRIs so this was Prozac
this was zoloft this was a black
jellybeans and this was a muscle
relaxant all of which were the
medications that the impatient was
taking so do you think the my self
administered antidepressants what's the
how did you know that they did this was
vodka in solution gin in solution hit
this guy also like plain water in the
muscle relaxant where's our exporter
vodka gin yes yes you know you're my
squirrel
yes so then the day I drank as much
vodka as they did plain water which was
interesting then of course the it goes
into the entrapment device there's an
old cell phone in there good use for old
cell phones which dials the clinic we go
and pick up the mouse we take the blood
sample and do the blood work and the
hair work on the mice and I want to sort
of point out the big advantage of
framing health in this external way we
do it a few prescription products
through this it's very different from
the medical model anything you do to
improve your water quality or air
quality to understand it or to change it
the benefits are enjoyed by anyone you
share that water quality or air quality
with and that aggregating effect is that
collective action effect is actually
something we can use to our advantage so
I want to show you one prescription
product in the clinic called the new
park this is a prescription to improve
water quality many in patients are very
concerned for water quality and air
quality what we do is we take a fire
hydrant and no parking space associated
with a fire hydrant and we prescribed
the removal of the asphalt to create an
engineered micro lens
to create an infiltration opportunity
because many of you will know that the
biggest pollution burden that we have on
the New York New Jersey Harbor right now
is no longer the point sources no longer
the big polluters no longer the GES
but that massive network of roads that
impervious surfaces that collect all
that cadmium neurotoxic and brake liners
or the oily hydrocarbon wastes and every
single storm event and medieval
infrastructure washes it straight into
the estuary system that doesn't do a lot
of good these are little opportunities
to intercept those pollutants before
they enter the harbor and they're
produced by impatience on various city
blocks in some pretty interesting ways I
just want to say that it was sort of a
rule of thumb though there's about two
or three fire hydrants on every city
block by creating engineered micro
landscapes to infiltrate in them we
don't prevent them from being used as
emergency vehicle parking spaces because
of course a fire truck can come and park
there they flattened a few plants no big
deal they'll regenerate room but if we
did this in every single every fire
hydrant we could redefine the emergency
rate that 99% of the time when a fire
truck is not parking there it's
infiltrating pollutants it's also
increasing fixing co2 sequestering some
of the airborne pollutants and
aggregated these small interceptions
could actually infiltrate all the road
borne pollution that now runs into the
s3 system up to a seven inch rain event
up to a hundred year storm right so
these are small actions that can amount
to a significant effect to improve local
environmental health it is one of the
more ambitious ones what the climate
crisis has revealed to us is a secondary
more insidious than more pervasive
crisis which is the crisis of agency
right which is what to do
somehow buying a local lettuce changing
a light bulb driving the speed limit
changing your tires regularly doesn't
seem sufficient in the face of climate
crisis
and this is an interesting icon that
happened you remember these fallout
shelters right there what is the fallout
shelter for the climate crisis
this was civic mobilization churches
school groups hospitals private
residents everyone built one of these in
a matter of months and they still remain
as icons of civic response in the face
of shared collective uncertain threat
fallout shelter for the climate crisis I
would say look something like this
or this which is an intensive urban
agriculture facility that's due to go on
my lab building at NYU what it does is a
very simple idea of taking 80 to 90
percent of the co2 produced in Manhattan
is building related we take just like in
a commercial greenhouse we take the co2
from the building
co2 enriched air we force it through the
urban agriculture facility and then we
resupply oxygen enriched air you can't
actually build much on a roof right
they're not designed for that so it's on
legs so it focuses all the load on the
masonry walls and the columns it's built
as barn-raising using open source
hardware this is a quarter scale
prototype that was functioning in Spain
this is what it will look like fingers
crossed and why you're willing and what
I want to show you is actually this is
one of the components of it that we've
just recently been testing which is a
solar chimney we've got 17 of them up
around New York at the moment that
passively draws air up you understand it
a solar chimney you know hot air rises
put a bit of black plastic on the build
on the side of a building it'll heat up
and you'll get passive air flow what we
do is actually put a CH standard HVAC
filter on the top of that that actually
removes about 95% of both carbon black
that stuff that with ozone is
responsible for about half of global
warming's effects right because it
changes it settles on the snow it
changes the reflectance changes the the
transmission qualities of the atmosphere
carbon black is that you know that grime
that otherwise lodges and your pretty
pink lungs and is associated with it's
not it's not good stuff and it's from
inefficient combustion not from
combustion itself but it
um when we put it through our solar
chimney we remove actually about 95% of
that and then I swap it out with the
this the students and actually
re-release that carbon black and we make
pencils the length of which measures the
grime that we've pulled out of the air
here's one of them that we have up now
here's who put them up and who are avid
pencil users okay so I want to show you
just two more interfaces because I think
one of our big challenges is reimagining
a relationship to natural systems not
only through this model of twisted
personalized health but through the
animals with whom we cohabit we are not
alone the animals are moving in in fact
urban migration now describes the
movement of animals formerly known as
wild into urban centers you know coyote
in Central Park a whale and the Gowanus
Canal elk and Westchester County it's
happening all over the developed world
probably for loss of habitat but also
because our cities are a little bit more
livable than they have been and every
green space we create is an invitation
for nonhumans to cohabit with us but
we've kind of lacked imagination and how
we could do that well or interestingly
and I want to show you a few of the
technological interfaces that have been
developed under the NAM occur of ooze
which is zu backwards and without cages
to try and reform that relationship this
is communication technologies for birds
looks like this when a bird lands on it
they trigger a sound file this is
actually in the Whitney Museum where
there was six of them each of which had
a different argument on a different
sound file they said things like this
here's what you need to do and go down
there and buy some of those health food
bars the ones you call bird food and
bring it here and scatter it around
there's a good person
so there was several of these the birds
were able to jump from one to the other
these are just to your average of an
pigeon and really test which argument
best elicited cooperative behavior from
the people below that a hundred to one
decided that this was the argument that
worked best on us tick tick tick
that's the sound of genetic mutations of
the avian flu becoming a deadly human
flu do you know what slows it down
healthy subpopulations of birds
increasing biodiversity generally it is
in your interests that I am healthy
happy well-fed hence you could share
some of your nutritional resources
instead of monopolizing them that is
shall lunch it worked and it's true the
final project I'd like to show you is a
new interface for fish that has just
been launched it's actually officially
launched next week with wonderful
commission from the architectural league
you may not have known that you need to
communicate with fish but there is now a
device for you to do so it looks like
this buoys that float on the water
predicts 3-foot up to be put down when a
fish swims underneath the light goes on
this is what it looks like
so there's another function on here this
top light is I'm sorry if I'm making you
seasick this top light is actually a
water quality display that shifts from
red when the dissolved oxygen is low to
a Bluegreen when it's dissolved oxygen
is high and then you can also text the
fish right so there's business cards
down there that'll give you contact
details and they text back when the
buoys get to @xp wink at you twice to
say we've got your message but perhaps
the most popular has been that we've got
another array of these boys in the Bronx
River where the first beaver crazy as he
is to have moved in and built a lodge in
New York in 250 years hangs out
so updates from the Beavers you can
subscribe to updates from him you can
talk to him and what I like to think of
is this is a interface that we scripts
how we interact with natural systems
specifically by changing who has
information where they have it who can
make sense of that information and what
you can do about it
in this case instead of throwing chewing
gum or Doritos or whatever you have in
your pocket of the fish in there's a
what a body of water in Iceland I've
been dealing with it's in the middle of
the city and the largest pollution
burden on it is not the road born
pollution it's actually white bread from
people feeding the fish and the birds
right instead of doing that actually
we've developed some fish sticks that
you can feed the fish they're delicious
they're cross-species delicious that is
delicious for humans and non-humans but
they also have a shear leading agent in
them they have their nutritionally
appropriate right not like Doritos and
so every time that desire to interact
with the animals which is is at least as
at least as ubiquitous as that sign do
not feed the animals and there's about
three of them on every New York City
Park and Yellowstone National Park
there's more do not feed the animal
science and there are animals that you
might wish to feed but the that that in
that action that interaction by Reese
crypting that by giving changing it an
opportunity to give off a food that is
nutritionally appropriate that could
have augment the nutritional resources
that we ourselves have depleted for
amending the fish population and also
adding a shear leading agent which like
any chelating agent that we used
medicinally binds to the bio accumulated
heavy metals and PCBs that are in the
fish living in this particular habitat
and allows them to pass it out as a
harmless salt where it's complex right
unless by a reactive effectively
removing it from bioavailability but I
wanted to say that that interaction we
scripting that interaction into
collective action collective remediate
of action right very different from the
approach that's being used on the other
side in the Hudson River where we're
dredging the PCBs after 30 years of
legislative and legal struggle GES
paying for the dredging of the largest
Superfund site in the world we're
dredging it and it'll probably get
shipped off to Pennsylvania or the
nearest third world country where it
will continue to be toxic sludge right
displacement is not the way to deal with
environmental issues right and that's
typically the paradigm under which we've
we've operated by actually taking the
opportunity that new technologies new
interactive technologies present to
reefs Crypt our interactions to script
them not just as isolated individual
interactions but as collective
aggregating actions that can amount to
something we can really begin to address
some of our important environmental
challenges thank you
all very funny you got me we are Intel
sponsors of tomorrow